with New Year's Eve just two days away
police in New York are announcing a new
change to the way they will secure the
annual celebration officials say as many
as two million people could pack into
Times Square to ring in 2019 with the
famous New Year's ball drop Kenneth
Craig is there with the latest on the
public safety measure measures Kenneth
good morning well good morning to you
Anthony police say right now there are
no credible terrorism threats but of
course they are not taking any chances
so in addition to the police officers
out here on the ground this year there
will be drones up in the sky watching
over the night's events people will be
safe on Monday and they should feel safe
too New York City leadership says
thousands of police officers will be on
patrol and more than 1200 security
cameras will be rolling as people flood
Times Square to watch the ball drop
it's a New Year's tradition spanning
more than a century
and earlier this week workers finished
installing the 12,000 pound balls
crystal paneling ahead of the big night
as in past years Times Square will be
protected by armed officers k-9 units
bag searches and trucks to block off
access to normally busy New York streets
last year's festivities were on high
alert because of an attempted terror
attack just weeks earlier when a pipe
bomb partially detonated in one of New
York's busiest transportation centers
now drones will join traditional
aviation units to surveil Times Square
from the sky we haven't done that before
but that's gonna give us a visual aid
and a flexibility New York Mayor Bill
DeBlasio stressed it's most important
for revelers to stay vigilant idea if
you see something say something although
we depend on the NYPD NYPD also depends
on all of us rain is in the forecast for
Monday night and officials are hoping
that doesn't damper anyone's spirits the
good news is it'll be a whole lot warmer
this year upwards of 50 degrees on New
Year's Eve compare that to last year
Michelle when it was the second coldest
New Year's Eve on record all right
Kenneth thank you